yeah to make important one-on-one
connections then mr. Gary Vee who is
somewhere welcoming people into the room
now let's give a big big big itself
myself west hand to JibJab
Gary Vee hello
so I mainly want to go into QA which I
will Huw your Q&A just now was riveting
I enjoyed it backstage I plan on doing
the same thing I'm not sure if we're
gonna throw up my hash tag but I think
it's askgaryvee vee
i want to welcome everybody to South by
I remember seven years ago when I came
to my first one I went to this session
you know when you're a noob or the first
time you know you kind of want to figure
out what what to do
I remember being enthralled with the
people that were on stage I was paying
attention very quickly and it was a very
good time as exciting time I hope
everybody has a great great weekend let
me get into the things that I think
matter and then I want to go into
questions and I'm thrilled to answer any
you know South by questions that I feel
I can answer but I know a lot of people
have been watching the Twitter stream
are here and have context on me and my
career overall so any questions I can
answer about anything from social to
selling wine what the Jets are gonna do
in the off season I'm thrilled to answer
all those questions when I think about
South by I think about it in the same
way I actually think about everything
else in the world which is there's a
couple core things that everybody needs
to do here I think to maximize their
experience the truth is and let's call
it what it is the reason most people
don't get the most out of South by when
they come is because the far majority of
people in this conference room right now
and the far majority of people in this
building and the far majority of people
that have come and visited Austin are
[ __ ] takers right and let's put that
into context the amount of people here
that will spend 98 percent of their time
saying hey check out my app right you've
got to check out my business or hey you
know you've got a really
come to my party or hey go do this or do
this for me do this for me give me this
give me your [ __ ] money for my piece
of [ __ ] start up come to my party that's
gonna suck [ __ ] you know all the people
are asking and it's really maps just to
what happens in the way we actually live
and the people that actually break out
are the ones that flip it I would ask
you if you want to have success or you
want to rock out [ __ ] South by let me
give you one basic thought that if you
can take the time for four simple to
simple days and for once in your
professional career have the patience to
actually provide value upfront and let
the cards fall where they will
afterwards I promise you the lifetime
value or the long-term value of this
event will be dramatically greater see
was one person clapping for that I just
I heard it over here it was that dude
right we need to hug it the [ __ ] out
after this talk actually come up right
now
let's [ __ ] provide value right the
[ __ ] now get up here dude hurry up dick
so let's think about what's happening
right now in real [ __ ] time right I
give my opening rant right you decide to
clap which brought me value because it
was positive reinforcement that I'm
looking for as a public speaker right I
then counter you doing a good thing for
me to bring you up here and now I'm
gonna give you 30 seconds to say hello
and tell the world what you're about
let's see how you do Kylie nice to meet
you thank you my name is Kylie Jordan
I'm a beat boxer from Atlanta Georgia
this is getting better by the [ __ ]
second do you see what I'm talking about
[ __ ] given good [ __ ] happens
[ __ ] Pete boxer there you gonna say
you're a [ __ ] UI designer or
something and I'm a UI designer no
really I build startups in Atlanta okay
will you freestyle yes okay Kylie's
parents had a real good marriage now now
we're gonna show people how South by
works now we're all gonna collectively
take out our smartphones which we
already have do you have a Twitter
handle all right now Twitter suck [ __ ]
and explaining how their product works
so do not start your tweet with Kylie's
Twitter handle say hey at Kylie oh
that's Kylie zero so Kile why the number
zero so now I'm gonna pause for 41
seconds while everybody takes out their
smart devices and says hey at Kile why
the number zero you could say he has mad
you know beatbox skills you could say
his beard is [ __ ] epic you could say
he's kind of cute you can say whatever
the [ __ ] you want but let's give this
man some love and let's clap it up for
him
listen there's gonna be the cool parties
to go to make sure you follow me on
Twitter for my secret wine party I'm
thinking about doing it tonight
so definitely come to that there's gonna
be the great keynotes there's gonna be
the things you want to get to but the
end of the day the reason I continue to
come back to this event while all my
douchebags Silicon Valley friends go oh
it's [ __ ] sold out it's too busy for
my [ __ ] dick [ __ ] you here's why it's
good and here's why I come back the
truth is there could be 9 million people
that come to this event you as a human
being have the ability to make this a
very big event or a very small event you
have the ability the reason I come back
is because so many of my friends who I
think are the smartest people in this
space and I will get together tonight at
one o'clock in the morning in one of the
hotel rooms and we'll do what we call a
jam session where for two to four hours
will literally debate is secret gonna
make money
what about Bitcoin did all the topics
that I'm passionate about being in
business living in this world about my
subject matter so I come to South by to
have lots of people who says it's not
about one too many for me it is right
now this is about one too many right
it's about one too many it's also gonna
be one to one when I was standing out
there on the way here I met a nice young
gentleman from Kansas City he's got a
fat ass
chief sad I see it right now and I got
to spend my two minutes with him know
that he's run a digital agency for eight
years and I got to have my one-to-one
moment me and [ __ ] Kylie we're
[ __ ] family by now right I got to
have that moment so I'm just really
[ __ ] tired of everybody saying oh
this is too crowded or this is too long
of a line or it's sold out or there's
too many people or you're 100 [ __ ]
percent in charge of your life stop
[ __ ] bitching
that's how I found value at South by
I'll tell you story my first year here I
came 2008 I was excited I wanted to meet
all the people
Tim Ferriss and Kevin Rose I was in it I
knew it I didn't you know I had the wine
show I was surprised how many people
knew my wine show cuz I didn't think it
bled into tech yet I've met Ram - Jason
freed you know and he said oh I love
your wine shows like holy [ __ ] Jason
freed from [ __ ] 37signals now I was
getting excited and it was the first
night I was getting pumped there's
parties I'm like oh [ __ ] nerd party's
cool so there was a party it was called
the 16-bit party right it was put on by
like Digg and a couple of other people
and I was super pumped I ran over to
where it was took one of these pedicabs
cuz I'm lazy and I don't like to walk I
got there and there's a [ __ ] line and
it's long
I don't like [ __ ] this log is long and
we're waiting and we're waiting and then
I finally got frustrated and I recalled
that you know eating my own dog food
about providing value up front
I did that before I came to South by in
2008 I shipped down ten cases of wine
from the wine library because I was in a
wine business at the time and that's
what I was doing and I brought it mainly
to share with people you know I figured
I'm gonna learn about tech I might as
well to educate these UI designers on
how to drink some [ __ ] Pinot Noir
so I shipped the wine down and I didn't
know what I was really gonna do with it
sure enough I'm sitting in line
everybody's getting frustrated the first
year South I was probably took a big
jump in like growth of people coming
people are frustrated by line so Twitter
was only about a year old I was doing
pretty well on it I'm like told my
friends and a couple other people let's
leave this line let's go back to the
hotel I've got wine right like free
liquor everybody gets [ __ ] pumped
right so we leave I tweet out with my
two thousand fans at a time like hey I'm
at the lobby of the Marriott hotel and
all these people started showing up and
really very honestly for a lot of you
that are curious that wine party now
called the secret wine party in 2008
early 2008 in a lot of ways was my
breakout moment in the tech space it was
the time when I got to meet a pharma
jority people a lot of people talked
about it but when you think about the
seed in which it came from I was
obsessed with the notion of paying
forward first I will promise you whether
it's south by whether it's the growth of
your business
whether it's the way you live your life
as a human being if every person this
room could actually figure out how it
actually works which is the leverage of
providing value first always puts you in
the right position for what you're
personally trying to achieve you have a
much bigger upside this is the event my
friend Andrew Hyde wore t-shirt in 2009
it said don't pitch me bro this is the
event where every single person comes
with an objective to close and the way
to actually breakout is to reverse it
you know to me this is an event where a
lot of introverts come that need to
figure out how to become extroverted
because it becomes an OP you know it's
kind of you know it's easy to say like
hey say hello to rain random strangers
right it's easy stand on stage for me
and you and say hello and do that but in
real life a lot of people are
uncomfortable with it you know I don't
know what works for you you know use
tinder I don't give a [ __ ] what you do
it'll be a lot of use tinder by the way
that's my third point use tinder that's
my third that's my third you know bullet
win at South by you know it's very basic
I think this is a great weekend I hope
everybody enjoys it I think that you
need to provide value I would stress
patience if you could be the second
person telling the person what you do
and what you want to happen you've
already won I do think that serendipity
matters I'll go a little bit left-field
on you though I actually use South by as
a 25% farming or retention play instead
of hunting and acquiring when somebody
says to you meet new people say hello to
the person you know the dumb [ __ ] that
people do have conferences like say
hello to the person to the left and
right of you that you're [ __ ] sitting
with I actually think it's a good idea
right now but you know but I don't want
to say it that way so I'll think of a
creative way to say it that's fine and
dandy and I would call that hunting
acquiring new people creating that
serendipity do not underestimate what
South by brings the table at scale of
actually connecting with old friends I
promise you that at least for me one of
the top value propositions that I get
from South by is when I live in you know
I live in New York when I'm in New York
I'm [ __ ] working my face off
spending time with my family it blows my
head off that I spend more time with my
friends in New York at South by than I
do in New York right so one thing I
would tell you is to kind of go through
probably your contacts on your phone and
think about people that maybe you don't
see as much as you'd like back home
they're probably here as well
I would allocate at least a good 20% of
your time trying to what I call farm
reinvest in the in relationships that
you already have instead of trying to
find new ones with everybody so that's
one that I don't think a lot of people
talk about that I would highly recommend
thinking about look you know I really am
uncut most of you a lot of you have a
feel for me I'm not super interested in
telling you how to handle your business
over the next four days I'd much rather
provide you guys value while I've got
you here in doing what I most believe in
I don't get to spend as much time with a
lot of you individually or even in a
collective group so can if you guys can
throw up the ask Gary Vee hashtag that
if you guys can bring up who's ever
asking me these questions that's coming
up here I'd like you to all to start
asking me questions I'd like to provide
value I have no idea yet I'm excited I'm
not looking I'm not looking I'm not
looking you coming what's your name
Shawn are you on Shawn I don't think
you're on can we put Shawn's [ __ ] mic
on Shawn Shawn Shawn Gary okay so he
just reminded you but please tweet your
questions to ask Gary Vee and we'll
filter through them with the help of our
friends at mass relevance and so the
first question comes from Brian Williams
and he asks can we ask the signer to
teach us how to say [ __ ] in sign
language it'll be a gift that keeps on
giving
signer interpreter I appreciate it
can you show the crowd how we interpret
the word [ __ ] fu CK and is that what you
do do you spell it out [ __ ] [ __ ] is not
sign language it's a gesture just let me
know thank you so much
there you go Brian alright our next
question is from Lisa root L and she
asks in your opinion what brands are
doing digital well would love it if you
named your top three picks so this is
always a tough question for the people
that don't know currently I'm running a
300 person digital social agency called
vaynermedia so we thank you so we have
um we have 80 brands that we're working
with for some of you here oh I think I'm
doing a book signing right after it's a
good time to plug it I'll be doing a
book signing right after this so if you
have your book or I think they have
books I'd love to see you so the book
that's there in the book that I'm just
reference to rings and I just brought it
up is I just wrote a book called Jab Jab
Jab right hook which looked at the
pieces of content that all the brands
are putting out there and who's doing it
best you know the truth is what's the
name of the person asked do you remember
Lisa Lisa um we said the problem for me
is I spend so this is a good good
opportunity for me to talk to you
philosophically of how I think about my
business one of the reasons I think I've
had success in business and all my
chapters of my career is I stay on the
offense and this is something I'm
completely fascinated by and so I want
to give this answer because I think it's
gonna help a lot of people in the room
no matter what you do I'm almost
incapable of playing defense when it
comes to business playing defense based
on this question would be me spending
time looking at what brands are doing on
Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
Instagram vine that aren't my own or
mine right because I want to see what
other people are doing there's a lot of
reason to do that
I respect why one wants to do that I
have zero
interest in that I spent absolutely all
my time looking at what I think human
beings are doing and trying to figure
out how to bring them value no matter
what the brand does or what it's all the
same game at the end of the day we all
know that we're getting bombarded with
brands businesses opportunities it's the
whole South by thing in a nutshell isn't
it the the real answer is how do you
provide value I don't need to see how
Puma or Nissan are doing it for me to
figure out how to do it best or how to
do it and so the truth is I I stay on
offense
I'd much rather test rinse and repeat
try to learn authentically and
organically with the community that has
opted in to hear from me then thinking
that there's any psychological
connection between a sneaker brand and
the cereal brand that I'm working on
right now so for me that is a very tough
question that I hate when it gets asked
because there's two ways for me to go
one I can answer it not authentically
and just headline read and pick a Taco
Bell because I've seen people say they
do it well the truth is I haven't done
the work to answer it the reason I don't
like the question is it sounds douchey
by not giving an answer some kind of
[ __ ] stuck on this tough [ __ ]
first question alright next question is
from Jim Forman he asked can you give
your sign language interpreter a pat on
the back I can't believe how well she's
keeping up with you a pat on the back
she's killing it absolute no wait
there's another person now let's give
for the interpreter a round of applause
please
and a pre-emptive one over here more
that was lame do it again
awesome let's go Steven and Contreras
well Google Plus ever be necessary so
this is a conversation I'm completely I
am stuck so I have been saving tweets
and opt-in pieces from my smartest
friends who say that Google glass is a
terrible technology and this is dumb
[ __ ] and it makes you look like a glass
hole and it's stupid and only nerds will
do it I am utterly stunned by the lack
of chess moves and seeing where guys
I've bad news we're all gonna become
[ __ ] robots and a lot of people are
sitting here and saying no it's the same
people that said they're not gonna go on
Twitter seven years ago or never have a
Facebook account or ever download
snapchat you [ __ ] liars right so
where I try to make all my money and why
I think I will be able to buy the New
York Jets one day is I spend all my time
thinking about what you think you're not
gonna do that I know you're going to do
now whether Google wins the game of
glass or Apple or Nike or [ __ ]
schmicker Magoo who's gonna be started
by two of you in here I have no idea but
if you are confused at the notion that
technology will be weaving into our
[ __ ] bodies you do not see what's
happening you how many people here by
show of hands and don't [ __ ] lie
lying is the devil how many people here
by show of hands and again I do not want
your head nod I'm not interested in your
half-ass fluttery hand full hands how
many people here in every 24-hour cycle
are always within arm's reach of their
cell phone raisin yeah bro
guys it's happening already it's
happening already the glasses are just
the next step in the equation and
whether it's glass and listen if glass
doesn't necessarily win whether it's
gonna be something else your piece with
a little screen here I mean how many
people here are willing to admit
that they would consider the notion of
surgically putting their phone into
their armored hand raise it no reason I
want you to reason and don't lie to me
raise it actually do me a favor just
important to me I'm gonna ask this don't
lie cuz it [ __ ] up the whole thing how
many people here are willing to admit
that they're willing to put surgically
try but to input their cell phone into
their arm if you're one of those people
please stand up please do that I just
want to see the numbers at this point I
would highly argue thank you guys I
would let's clap it up for these freaks
I would heart I would highly argue that
that number would be smaller 24 months
ago and that number is gonna be
dramatically greater in 24 months and so
I'm stunned by people's pushback on
glass when these are the people that
pushed for mobile phones when they
basically that same person ten years
earlier said phones were stupid and we
didn't need them it's the same old game
you know I think this is a foregone
conclusion where the robots are coming
next March chef Freeman says very
interesting to see you wearing an air
B&B top they are going to revolutionize
the hotel industry your thoughts mark I
wear this hoodie to remind me that I was
a douche and missed on investing in this
phenomenal company so I wear this out of
anger not happiness I don't think
they're gonna revolutionize the hotel
industry I think they're going to ruin
the hotel industry as we know it
I'm completely fascinated by marketplace
dynamics I was lucky enough to not make
the same mistake and invest in uber some
of you might know that I just launched a
new twenty five million dollar fund
called vayner/rse much of the focus will
be in marketplace
I totally agree mark I think they're an
incredible company run by really great
people gonna be really interesting to
watch them evolve over the next half
decade I would tell you for all the
entre how many people here by show hands
consider themselves
entrepreneurs just curious amazing so
for the more than half of you in this
room I would spend a lot of time
thinking every night no matter what you
do for a living of
where is there inefficiency in our
society and where will technology solve
that problem because I'm blown away by
people's lack of understanding that uber
and airbnb and things like storefront
they're just the beginning I mean we are
there is going to be a lot of stuff
coming in this space of creating
efficiency and you're seeing it with
like doctors and laundry cleanup
services they're just there's a lot
coming guys every person this room
values the following things in this
order I hope family and health money and
the one that most people don't talk
about time time is what we all give a
[ __ ] how many people here remember the
last time their internet in their office
or home that they've got accustomed to
was a hundredth of a second slower than
it normally is
you remember how [ __ ] pissed you were
time people use uber their buying time
not the service and so we value time
tremendously and convenience and all
these other things and so keep an eye on
that
Alexandr change yes how do you meet
relevant people at South by Southwest
you know Alexander I think the first
opening move is to get out of the
mentality of douchery that justifies and
categorizes people that did he seem
relevant I believe so did he that he I
want to make sure I'm using the right
word it was relevant
Alex honestly that I don't know like if
I could execute what was happening in my
stomach right now when I hear people
categorize other human beings as
relevant it makes me want to vomit on
myself
but I don't think you're a bad guy
Alexander III I think I think you're
asking a proper question I would say
first of all relevancy is massively
subjective right like there's people
that have a lot of followers that have
influence that are VCS that whatever
you're looking for I would tell you I
promise you that if it again I think
you're seeing a theme in my talk guys
I'm a very big fan of the second chess
move in life if you're just trying to
get to this person everybody's trying to
get to this relevant [ __ ] person and
so what happens is it becomes a supply
and demand issue where you're getting
pounded on you're not breaking through
because they're defending against the
supply but when Alex when you open
yourself up to meeting somebody who
might not be a relevant person by your
definition there are a shitload of
people running around in South by
Southwest
than if you have a drink with and say
hello or the exact person that's the
gateway to 30 minutes of my time at
South by Southwest but on paper with
their three hundred and six Twitter
followers it's not gonna seem so obvious
I promise when you stop strategizing
people's [ __ ] Klout and you start
acting like a human being you will win
give me some per that one you liked it
right give me a little something
Kylee Dorton your energy though how do
you sustain your energy though go ahead
how do you sustain it where is it where
does your work stamina come from like
highly Kali you're such a dick you
already had your [ __ ] 5 minutes of
fame guys let's collectively boo Kylie
now boom you [ __ ] six second you're
like a vine a like a six second you got
your five seconds all right I'll answer
it it's a good question
you know the reason why my answer is
because I think it's gonna come from a
good direction that I want people to cap
I think I want people to actually jump
on this bandwagon my energy all of it
all of it comes from one place gratitude
I am so grateful for the fact that I was
born in Belarus in a former Soviet Union
which is the least capitalistic place
and had the serendipity of luck to be
able to immigrate out of that country
when I was three years old and come to
this remarkable country for
Entrepreneurship you know I hate when
people hate on this country I wish my
dad was here right now when people hate
on this country
my dad's Russian accent hits like 11 on
the Richter scale he's like these
[ __ ] stupid Americans don't
understand and it's because there's just
so much good sure there's bad there's
tons of bad there's tons of bad in
everything but it's all about weighing
the options and so I'm driven by
gratitude that I was lucky enough to
come to this country and we're you know
being an entrepreneur is a celebrated
thing my kind of personality is a
celebrated thing I'm grateful because of
the health and well-being of my family
unfortunately for me I lost three of my
four grandparents before I knew them so
I've had a long run of living a life
without a lot of that ultimate pain I'm
grateful for the fact that my mother and
father though very different are an
incredible pair of parents that really
you know reverse-engineered who I was
about you know I'm an immigrant and the
way immigrants get out of their
situation which was we were poor is
through education at least on paper and
the fact that I was a DNF student and my
mom and then later my dad let me be the
entrepreneur that I was let me sell
$3,000 worth of baseball cards a weekend
even though I was getting F's enabled me
to become who I was and so I'm thankful
for that they were big thinking and
didn't get caught up in the conversation
of all their contemporaries
so I'm driven by gratitude I'm just so
thankful um you know how do you know how
grateful I am thank you do you know how
grateful I am that this many people want
to come in here what the hell I have to
say it's an incredibly ridiculous
feeling I was grateful when I had nine
Twitter followers let alone a million
like nine [ __ ] people want to hear
your two cents I'm just very very very
very grateful I will never take it for
granted I understand the perspective of
it all and I hate watching so many
people look at half glass full when
their glass is four-fifths fall
I'm grateful when I have one drop in the
glass because I'm like I know what to do
with that [ __ ] drop thank you
Matthew says you mentioned on help me
pronounce that James Johnson outfitter
show that you work 24 hours a day Monday
through Friday and unplug on the
weekends how do you manage to unplug
yeah I managed to unplug only because of
perspective about a year and a half ago
I was coming home and I got excited cuz
Lizzy and I my wife planned a trip to
Turks and Caicos for four days and I was
so pumped I couldn't wait to go with her
and I was so happy and then I got really
sad because I realized it was so why was
I happy I was happy because we had two
young kids and it's tough to get away
but you know just the two of us for four
days and spend some quality time
together and I got really sad math
because I realized holy [ __ ]
those last seven you know those last
five six years before we had kids when I
was building my library and Wine Library
TV and I went twenty four seven monday
through monday and i just kind of sat in
the cab it was a very short ride and I
was like you know I [ __ ] blew it like
I could have went on to more one-week
vacations with the woman that I loved
and that would have been ten amazing
trips of great memories and time
together that there's nothing I can do
to get that back and so you know I don't
think I'm super smart or really know
anymore than anybody or I'm so goddamn
great what I think I do well is I adjust
I'm a good halftime adjustments
I'm always auditing my life myself my
businesses the marketplace the
opportunities and so I took that moment
to say I'm not gonna wake up in seven
years and be like my kids are seven now
and they're always at soccer games every
weekend and this and that and so I
unplugged very easily once I made the
mental decision I always tell my brand's
my startups guys this isn't tactical
this is a mentality you have to decide
that you give a [ __ ] about your customer
not say it with some [ __ ] mission
statement on your about section right so
I would say things but I wasn't
executing against it I wasn't all the
way there I was still not there at that
moment I made that decision which then
made not checking my email or engaging
with you guys on the weekends
super simple because I knew what my
mission statement was I knew what I
cared about here and here and when these
two things connect game over so it's
been super simple but I needed to
remember that I was a workaholic an
entrepreneur I'm ambitious as [ __ ] so I
created a system that worked for me
right now and it will change but right
now my life going all-in Monday through
Friday which is 7 a.m. to 11 p.m.
working and then checked out on the
weekends and then going from two weeks
vacation to seven weeks vacation is
working for me and I've got another year
or two of it but then I know Misha is
gonna start stuff and I'm gonna want to
go to that game or that recital didn't
is that so I'll adjust but how do I
unplug
because I [ __ ] love my kids thank you
thank you Monica asked where is their
inefficiency in our society and how can
we improve Monica [ __ ] kind of
question is that I mean there's
unlimited inefficiency Monica here's the
way to actually answer it this is what
I'm trying to do I love this but here's
what I'm trying to do and figuring out
how to answer this question any time I
am frustrated because something isn't
happening as fast or as proper as I'd
like I find it to be inefficient so for
example I actively stand in front of you
right now with a grooming
cavity in my mouth there's a cavity
forming in my mouth and it's pissing me
off because I really need to go to the
depth I'm not joking I know everybody's
like what the [ __ ] is he talking about I
right now know in the top-left corner of
my mouth that a cavity is forming I'm
starting to fundamentally slightly feel
it it's gonna [ __ ] her
in a couple of weeks when it fully goes
to root canal phase right the reason
there's an inefficiency is I'm so
[ __ ] busy that I can't get to my
[ __ ] dentist right and I haven't
prioritized it mentally enough that the
pain for a day is worth the time right
now and I'm really upset about it if
there was an app like uber that let me
hit a button and a dentist could come to
my office I would do it right now
Monica let's start that service together
we'll call it tooth but the joke of that
all is I went into that rant is it's
true we prioritize other things over
other things and if we can figure out
where there's inefficiencies there's a
lot the next time you're frustrated
about being late or something's taking
up too much time realize unlike ten
years ago in 15 years ago when the
internet started hitting its groove when
entrepreneurs like ourselves started to
figure out how to fix this business the
infrastructure and scale wasn't there
every business that failed in 94 to 99
is actually gonna succeed over the next
30 to 40 years once the infrastructure
meets the mission and so it was too
early for uber couldn't have worked when
we didn't have cell phones at scale and
app culture and all these other
variables but it can today so think
about what the current technology can
solve that has already been accepted as
a non solvable issue because it failed
five to seven years ago
all right Stefan asks do you swear as
much when you pitch clients or partners
you know Stefan this is a tough subject
for me I used to have a lot of pride
five years ago in the fact that I really
only curse on stage mainly because I
grew up obsessed with Richard Pryor
right and I've been I've psychoanalyze
this cuz you know I curse a lot on stage
and it's kind of weird and there's
people in this room who have no idea who
I am
who've been turned off by my language
and can't hear all the other good stuff
so I've always psychoanalyzed that and I
convinced myself that well at least I
only curse onstage and I don't curse in
real life and that was true in two
thousand seven eight nine the problem is
and you can see where I'm going you
start getting into practice on stage and
starts slowly sweeping
to your regular life I don't curse
anywhere close to by percentage as I do
by stage but I've cursed that a client
here there and I in pitches I'm very
comfortable in Who I am I know what my
objectives are I know they're pure as a
matter of fact I sometimes use my
cursing as a filter to filter out people
who are only willing to look at surface
level who are not usually the kind of
people I want to do business with in the
first place
Scott Rodriguez says you're really big
about your word what's the biggest
personal sacrifice you had to make to
keep your word my selfishness the worst
thing about keeping your word is your
short-term selfishness right like
keeping your word costs you I'm so
[ __ ] pissed Scott at all the schedule
things that I have at South by over the
next two days you cannot imagine I
literally woke up this morning went to
go take a poop took my phone looked at
my schedule and I said holy [ __ ]
literally 80% of these meetings I do not
want to take there's too much going on
why did I do this and every part of my
body was like okay I'm sick okay wait
there's a big business emergency like
think about what I'm gonna tell my
assistant to say to these meetings that
I want to cancel right and I'm like I
can't do that because I'm petrified the
only thing I care about is my legacy I
like money but I've always been able to
make money right I'm obsessed with my
legacy
I'm obsessed that that young man with
the Kansas City Chiefs hat that I met
when he goes back home and my name gets
brought up he's like no no no he's
actually if he comes up like oh he
thinks he's the [ __ ] greatest
actually you know he's a nice guy like I
walked with him to his talk he was like
I think about that on a one-to-one level
every day of my life so what I'm
sacrificing is the short-term
selfishness that I want to do instead of
what I'm doing or use that money in a
different way or all these things
long-term though my biggest objective in
life my complete North Star is to have
as many people show up to my funeral as
possible sorry that's what it is Rebekah
Donahue says loved your newest book love
you Rebecca she loved you she loved your
book that's me bro you clearly never
written
book dick but just one bad tweet break a
brand or is it more about the overall
quality of content yeah Rebecca I think
this is the most uh this is the most
interesting thing I am dumbfounded by
the lack of knowledge that no one tweet
guys BP oil spilt all of the [ __ ] oil
in the world into the Gulf of Mexico and
you [ __ ] still fill up your car with
it and so do I there's a complete lack
of understanding of what cripples an
actual business the fact that
billion-dollar [ __ ] brands same room
scared that one tweet that wasn't so
good like woe is me we're gonna you're
not going out of business
idiot so you can see I'm excited about
this issue I believe intent Trump's all
I believe intent Trump's all we're all
gonna make a mistake I actually believe
that saying you're sorry in today's
society when none of us actually want to
say it is so powerful that sometimes I
think about doing things wrong just so I
could come out and say I'm sorry because
I think it's an actual net net positive
win for me and so yeah I mean I I think
this is a ludicrous conversation of
course you're gonna make mistakes
that's what happens when 22 year old
interns are managing your social media
and you know and that's what's gonna
happen and that's okay and you have to
go out and own it and say you're sorry I
promise you all the brands that are
worried about their tweets they need to
worry about their product they've got
bigger issues at hand than some random
tweet when they got a piece of [ __ ]
product you guys like that one huh
alright I'm paying attention all right
Molly asked which Bitcoin panel are you
most pumped about you know do you know
what kills me about Bitcoin is I wish
that I was smart if I was intellectually
smart not just emotionally smart I would
have made a fortune on Bitcoin I just
don't understand it whatsoever all my
friends all my consumers like you know
Gary they always start with like all
right you know central banking right and
I'm like [ __ ]
because then they're talking for 20
minutes and I'm like thinking about the
Jets defensive line cuz I don't know
what the [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] about central
banking and then of course I try to
educate myself and I google it and then
I get bored by the second line so no I
don't know anything about Bitcoin I
don't give a [ __ ] about a Bitcoin panel
I bought some Bitcoin at the height of
the market I lost I deserve it because I
didn't know what the [ __ ] I was doing
the daily pursuit wants to know what is
one sentence that inspires you every day
legacy is greater than currency done
I went long pause for effect
Daniel Ortiz asked what is your
prediction for the next big thing to
come out of South by Southwest this year
so I think a lot of people think that I
predicted things I've never predicted
anything right here's what I do vine
came out June 30th last year it came out
I knew it was already owned by Twitter I
knew the jack who has predicted things
that made things that became the future
bought it thus given me context to pay
attention to it so for the first two
weeks of February from 11:00 p.m. at
night when I got home till 2:30 in the
morning because I was executing on being
a good operator as a social media
thinker I used that product every day
and tried to understand it after
actually using it I figured out okay
this platform has a shot as somebody is
you guys know broke out in the early
days of YouTube I saw some parallels I
understood it and I went all in then I
started talking about it fast and
furious
I didn't predict vine I just fast
followed I have no [ __ ] idea what's
gonna break out of South by if anything
is gonna break out of South by what's
the next big platform here's what I do
know the amount of people that talk [ __ ]
about platforms that they don't use
blows my mind the amount of people that
like snapchats [ __ ] stupid I'm like
do you use it they're like no then I'm
like shut your [ __ ] mouth
right because if you don't use a product
how are you supposed to judge it you may
not also not be the target audience even
if you do use it so I don't predict
what's coming what I pride myself in is
if five
million people use a product a week
after it comes out it's worth paying
attention to like I spent my time on
jelly I spent my time on vine I spent my
time on secret you know I you know I'm
spending my time on this stuff trying to
use my filter to see if there's upside
I'm not predicting I'm executing yeah
Wells BOM asked if there was one feature
you could add to snapchat what would it
be I would like to do one too many not
in story form you know to met like I
actually send when I send snaps to all
my followers I feel like a far bigger
percentage doesn't go into the stories
UI and just goes in their normal UI that
they consume the snaps so I literally
take a picture sometimes and it takes me
60 to 90 minutes to hit all your [ __ ]
names one by one then it's really
inefficient one-to-many non stories
cameron hex asks hey askgaryvee how is
family life changed your business life
you know cam you know I grew up in an
immigrant family where family is like so
everything and then I came into my
family liquor store business so I was
all-in on that you know my own personal
family life has changed because you know
it's weird I was in provider mode from
like 17 so it's not like oh now I have
this responsibility I felt that
responsibility even when I came in I
felt like I had to pay my dad back for
what him and my mom did for me so I
guess the biggest thing is that you know
it's time allocation its work-life
balance it's figuring out what works I'm
sure the far majority of people in this
room to some level even if it's a new
boyfriend or girlfriend relationship
even if it's a best friend even it's to
a parent we all struggle with time
allocation of what we're putting into
what we're trying to build business-wise
and our careers and what we're trying to
do family wise the only thing I would
ask all of you I hate when people give
advice on this issue because it is so
one-to-one you know my wife is the most
independent woman I know that's the
foundation to why I can hustle as much
as I can because she's just she loves me
for what that is
she's very happy doing her jam and
doesn't need me to provide the time the
emotions and all that of course but so
everybody's got different situations
right and so what I would tell you is
the only thing I would give you advice
is try to hack whatever you're doing now
next year just try some sort of other
variable in it if you keep evolving year
after year you've got a chance to coming
up with a good formula
Eric Hubbell asked how'd you get Wine
Library off the ground going and scaling
well I mean Eric Wine Library was first
my dad's liquor store business called
shoppers discount liquors it was a three
million dollar year business that had
had four percent gross profits it wasn't
a net profit which wasn't making a lot
of money what I did with Wine Library
was pretty interesting it's the thing I
still recommend a lot of people here we
didn't have a lot of money Wine Library
com launched in 2000 1997 a lot of
people were not really buying online at
that point and so what I did was I just
got myself involved in the community the
same thing I did with Twitter and what
I've later done with any community what
I did was I went to forums and I just
became active in every single wine forum
on the Internet the way to build a
business when you have no money and get
a user base is by becoming one of the
users but acting like one of the users
instead of somebody who's pitching to
one of the users so I just had ultimate
patience I knew that nineteen ninety
seven eight nine ten a 102 or three was
a prerequisite to what I was trying to
build so when I was in the forum's I
wasn't trying to sell all these people
more Chardonnay or Bordeaux I was trying
to become one of them and by virtue that
set me up and the awareness of the brand
broken records what is one thing you
wish you knew when you started nothing
I'm fundamentally obsessed with the
climate I love climbing I actually do
not love the achievement if I knew
something before I started it would have
given me a quicker race to the
achievement of the goal I'm obsessed
with I love losing guys I love being a
Jets fan it's easy
I love the pain
sorry guy review I'm like I'm sorry for
you bandwagon Lakers fan [ __ ] you um I
love the journey
I love the climb so for me that
questions funny because I wouldn't want
to know I like the pain I like the
mistakes I like the grind I like it
Stirling doke wants to know what do you
think about retirement not like today
but the concept retirement yeah you know
I think for me I think we're all seeing
this right now I think work-life balance
is a big conversation I'm I'm a
workaholic I'm a hustler but I love the
fact that people are finding balances
that make them happy I think everybody
should do what makes them happy there's
plenty listen I have friends that are
gonna sell a start-up I have a friend
who SOLAS started for like a million
dollars and after taxes not a lot of
money in the scheme of things incredible
I'm not undermining that but he was a
young guy not necessarily in your third
at 30 to a million dollar exit with the
post taxes not necessarily something you
can retire on for the rest of your life
unless you're my friend who decides to
go to some crazy Southeast Asian country
I never heard of and smoke weed for the
rest of his [ __ ] life so you know I
think retirements different for
everybody the only thing I see my future
that doesn't look like building
businesses until the day I die
is spending an ungodly amount of time at
the racetrack so I will spend a good
portion of my time at the ponies and
betting on horses in my 90's but other
than that I'm working Marcus wants to
know beyond Angry Birds and candy crush
what's your take on the state of gaming
apps and what's next gaming and gaming
is the hits business games are in the
same exact business as movies and songs
it's a great business if you know how to
make hits if you're Steven Spielberg
you're gonna win if you're not you're
gonna lose so I think gaming is here to
stay it's growing it's a foundation of
how we live gaming has always been there
you know Hasbro and Mattel have built
big companies we like games we do it
forever people grew up playing video
games their whole lives now so in their
30s and 40s are still
gamer's it's a great business you just
have to be great at it
it is completely predicated on being in
the hits business so if you're one of
the best storytellers in that genre you
can win but it is dramatically more
competitive it blows me away how many of
my friends sit around brainstorming
business ideas and they're like let's
just build a game that weird guy just
had that [ __ ] bird game let's just
[ __ ] do that
are you out of your [ __ ] mind like
like you have no idea about gaming you
don't know you've never even hired an
iOS developer you have no idea about the
psychology of gamers you have no
understanding of the current state of
the union we are living through the
greatest generation of fake
entrepreneurs in the history of our time
right now and and that just means a lot
of people are gonna lose a lot of money
and that's fine cuz that's how it should
be because I was a fake digital currency
buyer and I deserved to lose so I think
it's a great space I think there'll be
lots of winners I think a lot of people
will make money and I think a lot of
people gonna lose money because it's a
little bit of a gold rush right now
Nicola Salter asked what shirt are you
wearing right now under the air B&B
jacket a plain grey t-shirt I'm waiting
Alex Cruz wants to know what do you
struggle with most when dealing with
your employees and keeping them
productive weird-ass answer the only
thing I struggle with with my employees
is to get them to believe me when I tell
them it is in their best interest to
play out their professional careers with
me
I have such disproportionate love for my
employees out of not being such a great
guy out of selfishness
I love continuity I love team I love
family
I am so ridiculously heartbroken when we
have to let somebody go or somebody
leaves that I still laugh am i it's so
it's awesome and I understand how good
it is for me but it's insane
how much it still affects me after all
these years I don't think they believe
me yet we're a new company
I've only been running vaynermedia day
in and day out for two and a half years
you know and I'm always scared if they
think I'm building a cult or that I'm
full of [ __ ] or they're cynical and so
everyday all I'm trying to do is figure
out what actions can I take one by one
with them to get them to buy in so that
they do feel jamming with me for next
two three four decades is a good thing
for both of us and so if I can convince
them that I genuinely want 49% of the
relationship and I'm willing to give
them 51 of whatever the pure sense of
the relationship is and I just don't
have the buy-in I have a lot more in
2014 I would say out of the 300
employees at vaynermedia I think I've
got 40 of them all in which is insane
because last year was probably 11 so I'm
happy I'm making strides but it's fun
for me as one keeps coming over to the
side and so I'm just trying I'm
struggling with the notion of how do i
authentically break through their filter
to make them realize how incredible this
journeys about to be
wait wire buzz says Lady Gaga or Madonna
were being very serious so first off
everybody should know I suck when it
comes to music like my skills when it
comes to music are awful like I don't
know [ __ ] about music so I'm trying to
think about this I would go with Madonna
because she has a longer track though
the current Madonna freaks me the [ __ ]
out but I respect the long term career
and her evolution you know I talked
about myself as somebody who likes to
adjust she [ __ ] adjusts right like so
that's where I go with at this point we
do have over eight minutes left so keep
tweeting Pete Dirksen said asks favorite
restaurants in Austin Pete this is gonna
really make you sad in the 8 years that
I've been here I don't even think I know
the name of one restaurant I've been to
it is insane of how
how little I pay attention to what where
and what I'm consuming when I'm at South
by echoing the theme that I've been
giving you the whole time I can remember
who I had the dinner with and what we
talked about but I don't know what we
were eating and so I know a lot of
people don't like to talk about barbecue
I don't know if I give a [ __ ] about
barbecue as a matter of fact I do I
don't give a [ __ ] about barbecue so
sorry man AJ Smith wants to know what is
your best advice or tangible advice to a
young 33 hungry financial adviser using
your principles you know AJ I would tell
you that the tangible advice is like let
me give you theoretical vison intangible
tangible is you know if you're a
financial adviser if you know exactly
who you're here's something everybody
should really think about if you know
exactly what you want to be you need to
spend as much time with people that are
actually that already I have this insane
concept of what MBAs should really be
doing like the thought like I've been
thinking a lot about like [ __ ] man like
these business schools are getting
$100,000 $200,000 putting these kids in
debt and giving them nothing that's real
in the actual business world versus the
leverage of the last 40 conversations
I've had with a business school person
is yeah you know the content isn't
really what I'm paying for
it's the relationships I'm like you can
buy those relationships for less than
150 you're a bad [ __ ] business person
the the advice I'd give you is if
there's a financial advisor that you
want to be like literally stop making
money right now and go spend a year with
her or him and figure out everything
that that person does take one step back
to go 10 steps forward that's what I
would do seriously by the way that's why
we do with every single person here if
you're a a solid UI UX designer that
happens to also be a really good
beatboxer and you think that there's
another great UI UX designer that you
want to be like I would really debate
taking one step back and literally going
to work for her for a year for half of
what you make now because the IP and the
nuances guys all the basic [ __ ] has been
figured out information is a commodity
like look it's never been worse to be
information smart than it is today
like remember 10 15 20 40 50 years ago
when being smart about something
mattered what do you want to know
everything you want to know is in your
[ __ ] hand on your phone informational
e I'm so pissed that my daughter is
gonna go through a school system where
they're gonna teach her information that
she has to memorize for a few minutes
for a test and then move on when that
thing is in her [ __ ] hand so we're
living in a world where all the I Q
value is shrinking by the second and all
the EQ value is exponentially exploding
as our reputations become more and more
of what matters and so I would tell you
to go and spend time with the person you
want to be like two things are gonna
happen one you might find out that you
actually don't like that person very
much and you're gonna when you dig under
the hood and figure out the nuances and
that will help you figure out who you
want to be as a person and to you may
find out that it's awesome and you want
to replicate those actions to get there
John asked what digital media skills do
you think students need to be learning
in schools today taking action you know
like a class in schools today they
should be handling Twitter accounts for
fake businesses they should be producing
content and making infographics for
Pinterest they should be buying ads on
the Outbrain exchange they should be
doing [ __ ] instead of memorizing [ __ ]
it's so obvious I'm actually so pissed
at this [ __ ] crowd for not clapping
more on that issue because it's so
ridiculous and by the way that's what's
going on in our organization I think
vaynermedia has exploded really quickly
because most of our 22 to 23 to 24 year
olds come in and are given the keys to
the cap they've to do a ton of [ __ ]
there's no get me a coffee in our world
they're like [ __ ] like go in like we
need far more openness and much more
entrepreneurial efforts in everything we
need to stop boxing people and it blows
my mind that this is America and most
corporate companies treat their
businesses like communism
they don't trust our employees they
don't let them do this they don't let
them do that there's [ __ ] 8,000
levels a process to eliminate that's
doing [ __ ] anything so royal amana
wants to know how do you find great
talent in terms of employees roy hire at
scale see this is where people are
confused I've seen every program every
thesis every great HR person every
process every test to find great
employees and lots of them don't work
out because once human dynamics happen
human dynamics happen the game guys
isn't if you're thinking about hiring
the game isn't about hiring smarter it's
about firing faster I'm being dead
serious don't [ __ ] laugh you know
they're like if there's not if it's not
working out you need to figure out how
to take that person out of the equation
you need to do right by that person one
of the things I do because this is my
thesis is I mentally think you're gonna
get paid for six months even though you
may get fired for two months do you know
what it looks like when you fire
somebody in two months and give them a
four month exit package that's what
makes me feel good about firing fast
it's still more valuable
it's about firing fast you just don't
know you just don't know you do
sometimes it feels right sometimes you
have an interview and you're like yes I
mean I remember interviewing somebody
and I was like this woman is gonna
change my business meant to be a very
positive thing that woman changed my
[ __ ] business
in a very negative way and took me like
six weeks to figure out how to get her
out of there and so you just sometimes
never know and I feel like I have great
EQ great judgment of character and I
miss all the time - it's not about how
you hire it's about how you fire
all right and Amanda Davis we'll have
our last question with do you have any
employees that work from home why or why
not I don't and this is a controversial
on a hoop jason Fried's not here I don't
because I'm selfish and I like team and
I want to see them and I want to hug
them and I want to see that they changed
her hair color from pink to blue and I
want to see their [ __ ] face and so I
I respect the value of why people think
working from home is awesome I I don't
think anything should be definitive I
understand why some people might want to
go for days and one day three and two
for me in the way that I think I can be
successful not only for myself but for
that employee I need to be in the same
places as them I need to see them I need
to feel it I need to taste the energy in
the room I need to look them in their
eye look in their [ __ ] ear I need to
look at them and so I can't have that if
they're at home and that's that's it so
for me it doesn't work in my businesses
I get to be a dictator you could be a
dictator in yours if you don't like my
[ __ ] idea and we'll see what works
for who and how but for me no all right
let's all give a thank you to Gary Vee
hold on Oh first I want to give you a
thank you for giving me your attention
you had plenty of things you could have
done second I'd love to meet some of you
one on one the best chance is gonna be
in the book signing
you know if the by a [ __ ] book I'm
playing the long game come and say hello
picture third I know a lot of you've
been to South by before I'm definitely
doing my secret wine party the wines
here I think I'm gonna do it tonight
follow it on Twitter and forth I love
you thank you